do you think
hitler could have been stopped one of
the things that's kind of fascinating to
look at is how many nations
both journalists and nations wanted
almost craved to take hitler's word that
he wanted peace
until it was too late they almost wanted
to be
deluded themselves i mean the same is
true with
this stalin people wanted to take stalin
at his word for still delude themselves
yeah that way we will do we we will
delude ourselves over any number of
things
and until even after the fact where the
history just says hey [ __ ] face
you know you you cannot supplement your
pseudo-reality onto actual reality here
anymore but yet we deal with people in
pseudo-realities constantly
it i mean it we will always find a way
to
to change reality to suit our needs well
the nature of truth now there's now
multiple
actual truths it's kind of fascinating
there's multiple
versions of history that people are
telling you know the the version
the version of the the the great
patriotic war in russia the world war ii
and russia
is very different today under putin than
the version that we're
learning on uh in the united states and
then different than the version in
europe in the united states
uh the the hero of the war is the united
states
in europe there's a much more sad and
solemn story of suffering and so on sure
and in russia it's the great patriotic
war
you know it was a unifier of a sense and
it
i mean yeah i mean you can't argue
that war and conflict that and or are
just even
um reducing that to stressors agitation
suffering doesn't create human
motivation you know we started this off
you brought up uh frankel
i'm like yeah frankel's dope my answer
is for meaning uh
maslow's great and and
i talked to you about how i started to
think like man
do the ability for human beings to to to
live and or potentially flourish in the
worst environments you can think of
is pretty incredible in and of itself
and that
it's a crazy thought to think that
without
frankel and maslow ending up in
concentration camps
do they write some of the most important
books on philosophy in the 20th century
and that's
insane on a lot of different levels but
uh yeah suffering is a creative force i
mean i don't
do you think we'll always have war yes
we will always have war
in some form or another we we need
quote unquote air quotes for those just
listening uh
war to survive we need war to flourish
we need at least can you explain the
quote
the air quotes well because uh take
just take take take to see wars as
violence no words got violence
so like so now it's because uh while you
know what
us getting on the mat or just getting on
these hardwood floors and wrestling
around
yeah is not literal war it's war
of a sort you know work you know it is
it is a deluded
form of war american football is a
diluted form of war all this
these are diluted forms of war tennis is
a deluded form of war
um and i think the one of the best
explanations i ever got from this
and another person very uh impactful on
my life and outlook and
thinking about things cormac mccarthy
and so in blood meridian there's this
fantastic speech about war given by
the judge which there's a ton of
fantastic speeches on things given by
the judge
yeah all that existing creation without
my knowledge does so without my consent
okay that's pretty heavy that's that's
hard
wait can you break that up can you say
it again uh all things that exist
and creation all things that exist
without my knowledge do so without my
consent
what does that mean well i think from
the judge's
perspective it's like well i didn't
consent to to that bird
or that dog or this building or all this
like all of this you know i didn't
create it so it's done so without my
consent
and if it's up to my consent well i'll
design it how i want to
there's a another similar uh look into
how the judge is in that book is
he would study everything
everywhere he went and so he's collected
this group of
nerdy wells from all over to go on these
hunts uh against uh certain uh tribes
in in the southwest um and getting paid
by the us government the mexican
government
so he's on these indian hunts
and yet they're going to all these
different places
and they would stay the night in a cave
somewhere and he would find cave
paintings he would write them all down
or he would find old pieces there's an
example of him
the narrator explaining how watching the
judge and
how he drawing everything he's got his
notebook just full of
things drawings and writings and
how he found like a piece of armor from
a conquistador or something way back in
the day of spanish armor he draws it
into his his book
and then crushes it yeah so that so
the reason we'll always have war in this
society is because there's this
struggle of amongst people that want to
be the designers
there's there's that but it's i'm just
saying that uh
he's got this whole quote on war like
war is about is
is play war is a game and the difference
is is that what's at stake
so all things are a game of some sort
and some you're putting up for it or
what you're willing to put up for it
determines whether or not you're going
to participate or not
and you know all aspects of
any game is war and it's just
what is at stake you know if it's your
life it's a different story if it's just
a coin
it's another thing a nice way to put it
is uh humans
play a game in this kind of pursuit of
uh creating whatever the hell the reason
is that we keep creating cooler and
cooler
things that that it seems to be the
result of a game that would naturally
play with naturally crave
i don't know i mean that's been the
struggle of philosophy
is to understand what is the underlying
force of all that is it the
will to power is that i think will to
power is a really great way of
of describing it do you want to be the
winner of the game
no not just no i don't look at wilted
power as being the winner of the game
well i mean if we're going to get
philosophical yes you want to be the
winner of the game
what does winning the game act define
how you win everybody's going to define
that win differently
you know you could define the win in the
most base level like oh i got all the
things
well if you got all those things without
the the needing component of fulfillment
then you're going to be a very unhappy
person with a whole lot of things but
there's a self-referential aspect to
where to me
the winner of the game is defined by the
people playing the game
so if i'm playing a game
i want to win in the sense that most of
the other people who are playing the
game will say yeah that guy won
by their by our collective definition if
i just come up listen i'm sort of
if i come out that's a lot of that's a
lot of weight on the external on you
right but that's that's how games seem
to work
somewhat so i'm already a winner in my
life
by defining my own different success
i'm i'm basically the best person in the
world at doing uh
uh me at being lex yeah so like and now
i'm really happy with that that's
that's the source of uh well i mean
think about yeah games are
also iterated right so you you start off
with your game
yeah and then your game with your
immediates
and then the game further than that the
game further than that and then the game
today and the game tomorrow
and the game next week and so it never
ends and
if you try to keep thinking about it
that way no wonder people go crazy but
we we don't want to think about things
that way we don't want to think about
uh being towards death we don't want to
think about um
whether or not i'm going anywhere after
this other than in the ground or what
have you like
you know all of these games are sense
some distraction this is where we
kind of but i mean it's violence is that
um we
need to let this out and so
it it is of our kids need to wrestle and
play
just like animals need to wrestle and
play we need to have forms of
competition we need to have ways to to
test ourselves
to create uh when
uh what is it uh when at peace a man of
war makes war with himself
and so we need to be able to competently
go at war with ourselves
and go at war with our neighbor and go
at war with our neighbor's neighbor
in a way that is repeatable at the very
least
so one one way of saying that there will
always be war i mean that's my
hopeful view is that most of the war
conducted in the future will be
like you said the man must go to war
with himself
that would be great that that's that's
what to me
love is is like focusing on yourself and
your own improvement
and your own creativity and towards
others
feeling uh sort of emphasizing
cooperative behavior
and compassion and would be great
empathy
it would be great but i mean you can
have
well i'll put it to you this way if you
have
uh a whole community of randians
and a whole community of and coms and
they could all like uh
i don't know a toast of london on
netflix and they love netflix and they
love the internet
and they love uh
picking apart moncomp with you they love
like they like all these
things even the esoteric that they can
they can they can get on
with but at the fundamental route
they cannot help but go to war because
they are literally oil and water
no they perceive but they would the
various
labels they assigned to themselves would
need to dissipate well this is really
well then you would have to stop being
whatever it is that you took on as your
ideological or
religious point right yeah i mean i
there's some days
i'm uh and calm some days i'm gonna end
captions
uh whatever the uh
uh knocking capital i mean it depends on
the the hour the minute of the day you
constantly changing moods and embracing
that flow the change of opinions of
ideas
as there's some days like i'm actually
cognizant of the fact because i've been
not getting my sleep
and after i get some sleep i see i'm so
much more optimistic about the world
the less and less sleep i get the more
sad cynical i guess you can see that
up and down i don't even let my well
okay
i try not to let and most days it's
never a problem
any sort of like uh what
the kids call it now black-pilled way of
thinking be
my my my over my the umbrella which i
hang under
you